what if I done what have I done  Oh what am I done  oh we said the lego movie last night so  good mr. half to see it every stone when  he saw it yeah that it was a movie oh my  gosh we saw the Lone Ranger last night  so good not have to see it yeah but were  you stoned when you saw it  okay the lego movie is this really solid  good hey man have you seen my lighter oh  no mine's blue bring that back oh no oh  no no no no no no half pepperoni half  cheese eight cheesy knots and garlic  butter sauce yes fine  thank you for calling scott's pizza we  are closed today you can find our hours  at our whip what if all my toys are  alive like they're in Toy Story  how do lava lamps work anyway the guy  who invented lava lamps was a nudist  there's a whole page is dedicated to  nudists sports tee loominatee I don't  play some real music off your father  yeah I got some really good stuff on  here let me find it  just water take on my phone